boston sitzungen koalition immer wieder
spielte auch manches handy eine rolle
bei diesen sitzungen und mario
brandenburg hat das zum anlass genommen
über
digitalisierung nachzudenken und genau
meine these die ich mitgebracht habe ist
dass wir in deutschland inzwischen über
digitalisierung sprechen übrigens nicht
genug wenn man sich die tri ace anschaut
aber ich frage mich ob das wirklich
ernst nehme ich meine politik und
gesellschaft denn das beispiel mit dem
handy zeigt wir sind schnell dabei
unsere verfehlungen auf technik
abzuwälzen ich glaube nicht dass die
handys aus der cdu sitzung getwittert
haben und dieses problem findet man
immer wieder ich frage mich nehmen wir
es wirklich ernst oder müssen wir auch
mal einfordern gesellschaft und
natürlich gelitten
wir müssen einmal erklären vielleicht
für unsere zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
armin laschet hat ein handy verbot
durchgesetzt jetzt künftig in
bundesvorstandssitzung und
präsidiumssitzung darf nicht mehr das
handy mitgenommen werden offenbar bei
den cdu kollegen wie es bei ihnen hat
christian lindner der auch schon
durchgegriffen oder nehmen wir dürfen
alles mit einem handys tablets sogar
wenn man wollte bestimmt auch einen
personalcomputer wie es früher war das
problem ist eben nicht die technologie
das problem sind die menschen und ich
den bogen gespannt wenn
technologiepolitische sprecher ich sehe
ähnliches bei künstlicher intelligenz
man liest immer die diskriminiert naja
es ist zum ersten mal dass wir in den
daten gefunden haben dass wir
diskriminieren nur dann werde die
misswahl regulieren das müssen wir
bieten und ich frage mich wie wir
wirklich vorwärts kommen wollen in
diesem land wir sind so weit hinten wenn
wir bei jeder kleinigkeit die technik im
prinzip auf den scheiterhaufen opfern um
uns unsere verfehlungen da raus zu
nehmen und das macht mir natürlich angst
wenn der cdu die sich das auf die fahnen
geschrieben hat dann auf so kurz
gedachte lösung kommt aber paul das war
doch weil das nicht war das nicht
katastrophal
das meint armin laschet geht da in
diesen parteitag der jungen union oder
dieses zusammentreffen der jungen und
nun hält eine flammende rede für
wolfgang schäuble dem man sein
abgeordnetenmandat nicht nehmen darf
weiß nicht wer das will aber eher gut
aber er hat zum angriff er hat den zu
verantworten oli dass der im diebe
wolfgang schäuble der verdiente man
nicht mehr bundestagspräsident sein
werden wird sondern
abgeordneter armin laschet mit seinem
licht mögen das ist ja nur so und dann
wird dieser beschluss den eu zieht paul
ja von der junge union gekippt die haben
gesagt wir wollen das nicht das kann
immer sein handy neben carina steht also
die komplette niederlage obwohl ich muss
zur armenische daneben zur verteidigung
sagen bei der um junge union hat er eine
rede gehalten also im vertraglich nein
es stimmt nicht aber ich finde ihn
sollten monaten ich hasse nichts mehr
als wenn menschen in der presse getreten
und gefedert werden und ich neige dazu
wenn jemand so stark gefühlt wird auf
die andere seite armin laschet muss ich
sagen es gibt eine aussage da bin ich
auch der meinung aber ich bin mir
einfach von hand und lächelt wenn ich
ihre feste überzeugung dass er als
verlierer gerade bei der jungen union
das war eine gute rede erstand gut da er
nimmt diese rolle alle waren
ich finde man muss auch mal sagen
respekt für armin laschet der se arm
genug dran aber jetzt geht ja ums ag
liefert nochmals dass in der regierung
sagt das ist ja im bezug auf
gremiensitzungen der partei läppisch
dann hat nimmt man das handy halt eine
halbe stunde später und fängt dann an zu
twittern es gibt für mich ein großen
unterschied zu einer ganz anderen sache
die mir immer unangenehm aufgefallen ist
nämlich den bundestag da sitzen alle da
und fummeln an ihren geräten rum und
vorne hält einander redet ja keiner
zuhört erschien das ist ganz viel flair
also ich würde die handys vor der
bundestags vor den türen des plenums
einkassieren damit die drinnen sitzen
und gefälligst zu hören und das ist ja
ihre arbeit das ist ja keine höfliche
napoli desto hat wie eine schule ein
lächeln jährige das ist doch dieses hast
du es mal gesehen
den respekt einen anschaulichen aber
nicht verbot gibt bringt doch nix
natürlich kann man einfach vertreten und
wenn erst nach wenn etwas dringendes zu
regeln gibt dann hat man ihren telefonen
das ist nämlich da kann man das büro
anrufen solle doch mal den durch los so
und so na ja ja ja dann kann auch jetzt
kein handy verbunden
schüler ein natürlicher jeder windows
weitergehen also da sitzen leute zehn
außen ab ich bin natürlich bei
sicherheits bestehenden regeln geben
sich mühe tragen sich vor keiner dazu
was ist das was der herr ist das
deutsche parlament das hat doch dann
aber theoretisch was mit anstand zu tun
das mit dem handy verbot das ist genau
der punkt auf wen ich wollte also meine
meine schulische bildung war glaubt
pager verbot dann tamagotchi kaputt dann
telefonverbot dann war es ein handy
verboten zum schluss war es irgendwann
haben wir dann gehalten ich würde
informatiker anscheinend weil ich
rebelliert habe aber wie soll wie soll
denn diese gesellschaft mündig im umgang
werden wenn die lösung immer verboten
ist da wollen wir das war nur ein
kleines beispiel und deswegen sind wir
bei technologien bei gründungen hinten
dran weil wir kein attraktiver markt
sinn wenn wir alles was wir nicht mögen
entweder verbieten oder vor der tür
warum es dass man den abgeordneten
abnehmen damit sie verdammt nochmal ihre
arbeit machen der das plenum und dort zu
hören und mit debattieren ist ein teil
ein wichtiger teil ihrer arbeit das ist
das sagen ja alle bei allen schönen
sonntagsreden die herzkammer der
demokratie da sitzen ja darum und
formeln um das stimmt ich bin mir sicher
dass viele zu hören aber was ist nicht
auf die medien schaffen die sich über
tweets aus den plänen von 1 ich nicht
aber ich sehe sie unten ja wie sie da
auf ihrem gerät rumfummeln sie sind
digital ist nach oben da geht es aber
relevant ist die herzkammer der
demokratien genau deswegen ist eine
berichterstattung aus ihrer genauso
richtig natürlich ansehen handy alarm
auch richtig von bild ich ja gut in
leise ja
schon richtig wenn sie sagen das ist
dann ist er in frankreich wünsche nicht
mitnehmen weil das erwachsene gewählte
menschen ich gebe zu das ist natürlich
kein übermaß nehmen darf bald ist
einfach dann höflich wie aber
fairerweise die fachpolitiker in den
vorderen reihen die hören da zu sitzen
aber inzwischen über 700 theoretisch ich
würde mal interessieren ist das in ihrer
fraktion mal diskutiert worden wie man
sich davon ein weil
ich finde auch also ich bin ja oft einer
meinung aber jetzt dass wir wie bei
unter 16 die bei kindern da die handys
einkassieren und dann was ist denn wenn
jemand zwei hat machen wir gucken wir
alle ob irgendwo noch ein verstärker
apple holt apple oder organe
regierungsbank sollte das so sein weil
da guckt ja jeder drauf wie wenn da kann
man schon erwarten dass die dann und die
haben ja alle ihre referenten da hinten
und da können auch mal einer für ein was
was suchen oder sonst was ja da hast du
da ist da habe ich mitleid aber ich bin
also ich würde mich da zurückhaltend
brot angeht ich finde grundsätzlich ist
es natürlich quatsch da ein verbot zu
erteilen am ende zeigt es doch wie
geschlossen oder diszipliniert eine
partei in einem bestimmten zeitraum ist
und ich glaube auch es ist nicht eine
besonderheit der union sondern das gab
es bei der spd das besondere 29 10 11
bei der fdp bei den wirren um guido
westerwelle philipp rösler da wurde auch
immer alles raus gestochen und jetzt
eben bei der union das ist eigentlich
ein zeichen sozusagen eines wandels den
eine partei dringend braucht und dann
ist das zeichen dort das eben sehr viel
debattiert wird und wenn man sich
dagegen anschaut das muss man ja also
leider für uns journalisten und muss man
das anerkennen dass aus den ampel
sondierungen bislang eben kaum etwas
ausgedrückt listen und sowieso an dir
was ihr interesse weil journalisten
können ein anbieter ja dieser dieser sms
erkennen welche intrigen laufen das ist
hochinteressant man weiß dann auch wenn
die abgeschickt hat paul ronzheimer
kriegt die meisten na ja weiß ja viel
aus der cdu wäre da wer da wen
intrigiert könnte er ganz so spannend er
ganze bücher darüber schreiben das ist
für journalisten hochinteressant aber
für die partei ist es mist und
erstaunlicherweise wurde dieses ja wenn
wir es vakuum dieses gelübde heute
durchbrochen durch annalena baerbock mit
dem hinweis dass der soli so bleibt wie
er ist fand ich sehr spannend mal gucken
was da kommt ich denke da werden wir
noch weitere positionierung auch über
öffentliche führungen elia absoluten
[Musik]